sécurité sociale employeurs et salariés
cotiseront davantage aux mavs légère
régression d'une session extraordinaire
du parlement pour revoir l'indemnisation
hussein de north de jordanie homme clé
de la paix au proche orient
invité de ce journal scandale en
grande-bretagne
l'ancien leader libéral dans le médoc
sera jugé pour incitation au meurtre
même messieurs bonsoir cadre inhabituel
pour le conseil des ministres de ce
matin le centre nerveux du pouvoir
s'était déplacé d'une dizaine de
kilomètres les ministres le chef du
gouvernement et le président n'était pas
à l'elysée mais dans un pavillon de
chasse à marly le roi ceci parce que la
présidence de la république s'apprêtait
à recevoir plusieurs centaines d'enfants
pour le traditionnel noël de l'elysée
nous en reparlerons à la fin de ce
journal avec le sourire mais pour
l'heure où vont tout de suite le plus
gros des dossiers abordé en conseil ce
matin le déficit de la sécurité sociale
des visites cumulées qui nous vous
l'avons souvent répété s'élèvera l'année
prochaine à 17 milliards de francs
alors qui paiera et bien essentiellement
les salariés qui sont au dessus du
plafond actuel de la sécurité sociale
4000 francs donc surtout en ce qui
concerne l'assurance maladie et dans une
moindre mesure l'assurance vieillesse +
4 % pour la maladie répartition égale
entre employés et employeurs plus 1,75
pour cent pour la vieillesse charge deux
fois plus lourde pour les salariés que
pour les employeurs alors tout de suite
avec vous vous le rendra pas le détail
de ces mesures gouvernementales a bien
su d'abord vous donner quelques exemples
parce que ce que cela représente pour
les cotisations des salariés
mettons un salarié qu'il ya une 2000
francs ils paient actuellement 159
francs à la fin janvier 1979 il fera en
plus 25 francs un salarié qui gagne
4500 francs actuellement comme
cotisation 356 francs 85
il perd à 56 francs de plus passons à un
salaire de 9000 francs
la cotisation salariés et 2 423 francs
elle sera augmenté de 146 francs alors
pour la conséquence voyons maintenant le
remède comment également s'y est pris
pour trouver ces 10 milliards vient donc
le gouvernement cherchait 17 milliards
il a d'abord essayé de faire des
économies pour combler ce déficit et ses
économies il cherchera à les obtenir en
freinant l'accélération des dépenses de
santé hospitalisation médicaments
médecins essentiellement il cherchera à
avoir une hospitalisation mieux gérer il
demandera aux médecins si possible de
rendre les ordonnances moins lourde
ce freinage pourrait permette de réduire
à peu près d'un milliard le déficit
prévu ensuite le gouvernement
cherche à trouver des ressources ses
ressources elle viendrait de trois
grands postes une augmentation des
cotisations vieillesse de 1 28 75% dans
la limite du plafond
le rendement attendu et 2,8 milliards et
demi un déplafonnement des cotisations
d'assurance maladie de 4% qui
rapporterait 4 milliards et demi alors
plafond des plafonnements je vous
expliquerai tout à l'heure ce que
représentent ces mots ces deux mesures
entreront en vigueur en janvier 79 il
est une autre mesure c'est la création
d'une cotisation pour les retraités sauf
les moins favorisés cette cotisation
serait de 1 % sur les pensions 2% sur
les retraites complémentaires
on en attend un rendement de 1 milliard
deux parents mais il est vraisemblable
que cette mesures n'entrera en vigueur
qu'après quelques mois car elle a besoin
d'être votée par l'assemblée avec
d'autres mesures moins importante
augmentation de la taxe sur l'assurance
automobile et l'augmentation des
cotisations des salariés agricoles
on arrive au compte à peu près de quinze
15 à 17 milliards de francs
alors voyons ce cas tu as directement
les assurés sociaux surtout les salariés
à ces notions de plafond et des
plafonnements oui alors la nouveauté des
mesures c'est le déplafonnement alors
c'est un peu compliqué je vais vous
l'expliquer les cotisations de sécurité
sociale actuellement sont calculées en
pourcentage du salaire mais la plus
grande partie des cotisations de son
prise qu'en dessous d'un plafond le
plafond est avec la venue naturellement
de 4000 francs ce qui fait que pour
quelqu'un qui gagne 4000 francs ou
quelqu'un qui gagne 10 mille francs
les cotisations sont à peu près les
mêmes sauf pour une petite fraction
actuellement elle est de 1 25% qui porte
sur l'ensemble dû s'élève alors à partir
de janvier prochain ça va changer à
partir de janvier prochain
cela change est d'abord un détail qui
est automatique qui arrive tous les ans
en fonction de l'évolution des salaires
mais ce qui va se passer c'est vous le
voyez ici c'est un passage des
cotisations sous plafond qui diminue aux
cotisations sur l'ensemble du salaire
qui augmente et finalement c'est ça
qu'on appelle le déplafonnement on
enlève un peu de ce qui se trouve sous
le plafond on en met plus sur l'ensemble
du salaire alors voilà maintenant pour
le détail il faut voir même avec le
ministre de la santé en charge du
dossier depuis plusieurs années simone
veil la philosophie et l'esprit de ces
mesures
simone veil qu'a rencontré laurence
graff a tout à leurs attentes et de
répartir la charge équitablement en nous
inspirant tout d'abord d'unité de
solidarité et donc de déplafonner les
cotisations d'assurance maladie étant
observée que par cette mesure ne
touchons pas même mot retraite
complémentaire des cadres ce qui était
pour eux très importants et par ailleurs
de ne pas trop alourdir les charges des
entreprises car on sait qu'en ce moment
pour l'emploi il est très important que
les entreprises ne soient pas trop
lourdement chargé mais alors vous voulez
faire des économies sur la santé c'est
un peu inquiétant julio non pas du tout
nous voulons pas faire des économies sur
la santé telles par rapport aux dépenses
actuelles ce que nous voulons c'est
infléchir la croissance dépenses de
santé il faut savoir que depuis
plusieurs années chaque année on
constate une augmentation de plus de 20%
des dépenses santé c'est à dire beaucoup
plus que l'évolution du coût de la vie
ce qui devient tout à fait insupportable
et c'est ça qui implique chaque année
des augmentations de cotisations assez
fréquemment ces augmentations de
cotisations alors nous voulons ramener
l'augmentation des dépenses de santé à
une augmentation plus proche de
l'évolution du coût de la vie et se
lassent naturellement sans porter
atteinte à la qualité des soins
simplement en supprimant toutes les
dépenses qui ne sont pas utiles par
exemple des gens il y à des lits
d'hôpitaux qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
pas pleins et bien cela crée une dépense
il faut donc adapter tout à fait la
capacité des hôpitaux aux besoins de
même il y a quelques fois des
gaspillages en matière de médicaments
là aussi il faut éviter tout ce qui
n'est pas une dépense utile pour la
santé n'est en revanche pouvoir comme ça
faire bénéficier notre système de tous
les programmes et une catégorie
particulièrement touché par ces mesures
sont les cadres
que répondez-vous à leurs protestations
oui alors je crois que au contraire nous
avons pris des mesures importantes pour
épargner les retraites complémentaires
des cadres qui sont pour eux quelque
chose qui est particulièrement important
pour leur protection sociale et donc
nous n'avons pas augmenter les
cotisations des caisses au dessus du
plafond
nous avons effectivement déplafonner les
cotisations d'assurance maladie dans une
perspective de solidarité estimant que
les français devaient contenu d'un
revenu participer à cette possibilité
ouverte à tous les français de pouvoir
se soigner dans les meilleures
conditions
alors les réactions ça décale n'ont pas
tardé et elles vont continuer à tomber
d'ores et déjà force ouvrière annonce qu
elle revendiquera une majoration
salariale l'année prochaine pour
compenser la réduction du pouvoir
d'achat des assurés sociaux le cidunati
estime que ces mesures ne vont pas
manquer d'accroître les difficultés que
connaissait entreprises indépendantes
mais c'est comme prévu les 4 de la cgc
qui par la voix d'yves ans charpentier
se sont montrés les plus inquiets eh
bien je dirais que le gouvernement a
choisi la voie de la facilité de la
démagogie et du manque de courage dans
le domaine de la maladie
on veut faire supporter aux seuls
membres de l'encadrement et aux
entreprises
le déficit et on transforme un régime
qui rendrait responsable les intéressés
le régime d'assurance un véritable
régime d'assistance fondait sur un
espèce d'impôt progressif
proportionnelle dans nos veines la
vieillesse at on eu le courage de
regarder ce que représentait la charge
pour les actifs et de mettre fin au
scandale du cumul willy anna qui
contribuent au trou de la rage de
l'assurance vieillesse de la sécurité
sociale tout en ayant un emploi
cela exige du courage le gouvernement a
choisi la voie de la facilité adopté
d'ailleurs des mesures du programme
commun est en tout cas renoncer
totalement au promesses et aux
engagements qu'il avait pris à blanc
la cgt de son côté appel à une riposte
nationale de très grande envergure ces
mesures représentent dit l1
nouveau coup porté à la consommation
populaire est pour l'instant pas de
réaction de la cfdt deuxième dossier
abordé par le président et les ministres
matin la réforme de l'indemnisation du
chômage c'est un projet qui sera
présenté au parlement au cours la
session extraordinaire s'est confirmée
qui se tiendra avant la fin d'année
c'est à dire sans doute à partir du 22
décembre le gouvernement a retenu le
principe d'une loi cadre plus simple et
plus efficace
c'est à deux objectifs que doit répondre
cette loi cadre
d'abord la simplification actuellement
les chômeurs reçoivent deux sorts
d'indemnités une versées par l'unedic et
l'autre par l'état pour simplifier cela
il est proposé que les deux systèmes
soient confondus et ne dépendent plus
que de l'unedic
en contrepartie l'état verserait une
cotisation annuelle à l'unedic
cotisations dont le montant n'est pas
encore fixé
efficacité ensuite pour rendre ce
système plus incitatif à la reprise du
travail
laza c'est à dire les 90% qui concerne
actuellement 174 mille chômeurs coûte de
plus de six milliards par an ne
viendrait dégressive dans quelles
conditions peut être 90% les trois
premiers mois puis 80 et 70 %
cela n'est pas fixée par le projet de
loi et fera l'objet d'une négociation
entre le patronat et les syndicats
l'allocation de base que qu'elle soit
actuellement 330 mille chômeurs et qui
s'élève à 40% de l'ancien salaire plus à
35% verrait son taux relevés pour passe
à combien 45 50 ou 60%
là encore le taux n'est pas fixée par
cette loi cadre
il sera lui aussi négocié entre les
partenaires sociaux
les autres indemnités est telle que la
pré retraite et la location de premier
emploi ne seront pas modifiés enfin dans
l'hypothèse où dans les mois à venir
les dépenses seraient supérieures aux
recettes et bien ce déficit serait
comblé aux deux tiers par les employeurs
les salariés et pour le tiers restant
par l'état robert boulin le mythe du
travail qui s'occupe de ce dossier
étaient depuis quelques heures en
possession du chiffre des chiffres du
chômage pour le mois de novembre
ils sont en régression en très légère
régression un million trois cent trente
mille demandeurs d'emploi c'est-à-dire
14 mille de moins que le mois précédent
je parle toujours en chiffres bruts et
non pas en chiffres corrigés des
variations saisonnières qui sont eux un
petit peu plus faible malgré tout il
faut attendre pour les mois à venir à la
comptabilisation des licenciements
annoncés vous le savez depuis le début
de la semaine dans la sidérurgie et qui
provoque toujours les mois dans les
régions concernées
je devrais dire les régions sinistrées
sos disent toujours les habitants de
longwy en lorraine manifestations
répondant nécrose de denain dans le nord
plusieurs députés ont d'ailleurs
interpellé le gouvernement à ce propos
cet après midi l'assemblée lé socialiste
françois mitterrand yvon ton dont le
communiste bocquet et le rpr fringale
réponse de raymond barre
une nouvelle convention sociale doit
intervenir dès le mois d'avril
après négociations avec les
organisations syndicales intéressés
cette nouvelle convention sociale
permettra de définir des solutions aux
individuels qu'ils soient les plus
humaines permettant au personnel dont
les emplois sont supprimés de trouver de
nouvelles activités
ne confondons pas des suppressions
d'emplois et des licenciements créateur
de chômage déjà des mesures sont
intervenues
la question est trop sérieuse
je vous demande de me laisser parler
ne confondons pas ne confondons pas
suppressions d'emplois et licenciements
je rappelle que les suppressions
d'emplois intervenus dans la sidérurgie
en 1977 et 1978 ont pu s'opérer pour la
très grande majorité des travailleurs
concernés sans création de situation de
chômage petites touches rose dans ce
tableau bien noir les investissements
industriels devrait être meilleur
l'année prochaine il devrait augmenter
de 7% nous dit l'insee
alors que cette année ils ont
pratiquement stagné conférence de presse
de georges marchais après le comité
central de son parti pendant deux jours
le leader communiste s'est déclaré très
intéressé par la déclaration de jacques
chirac à propos de l'europe ainsi que
par le vote des députés rpr avant-hier
ce n'est pas la première fois que nous
retrouverons quand les intérêts de la
france autant jeu a dit georges marchais
mais le numéro un communiste a toutefois
souligné que le rpr faisait encore
partie de la majorité giscardienne du
côté des socialistes maintenant tous
ceux qui ont soutenu françois mitterrand
congrès nantes il y a un an et demi
c'est à dire tous les socialistes
l'exception du crs ou est un petit peu
ce tester voir si la cohésion la
majorité du parti tenait toujours
après les coups de boutoir des uns et
des autres noël copains qui viennent me
téléphoner me dit que les travaux ne
sont pas encore terminées je pense
qu'ils en rendra compte dans notre
dernier journal vers 23h30 les
communistes italiens diront non à
l'entrée immédiate de l'italie dans le
sm
en fait est une négation toutes
conditionnelles qui portent
essentiellement sur la date d'entrée le
p6 n'est pas hostile à l'écu sous
réserve d'une garantie sony rupture
quand même au sein la majorité dans le
gouvernement de ioulia andreotti mais il
ne semble pas qu'il soit menacée dans le
scrutin de cette nuit valéry giscard
d'estaing a répété sa satisfaction ce
matin de voir l'italie grossir les rangs
du sm
fin des entretiens avant ce béguinage
jérusalem et rienne positif pour le
moment au bout de ces deux heures de
discussions sérieuses 27 force de mettre
un peu d'huile dans les rouages grippés
des négociations de paix
israélo égyptiens de la paix au proche
orient un des hommes clés le roi hussein
de jordanie
le souverain hf demain sa visite en
france il est avec nous ce soir dans ce
journal
merci majesté d'être notre invité la
première question je m'oppose et parce
qu'on a un petit peu de mal à comprendre
votre position quand allez vous signer
cet accord avec israël
vous ne condamnez pas vraiment le
président sadate vous n'êtes pas non
plus tout à fait avec les pays du front
refus alors on a envie de vous demander
quand allez vous signer un blé vote
besoin du ponceau mais il faut croire
que nous ne pouvons intervenir lit-on
dans un processus dure depuis qui
conduirait à une paix juste et durable
au moyen-orient que dans la mesure où
toutes les autres parties concernées
interviendront cela signifie les
palestiniens les syriens regard de rein
et toutes les autres parties du côté
arabe et avec l'aide du restant du monde
mais kana faute nous espérons que l'on
pourra faire un effort pour rétablir une
paix juste et durable fondée sur les
principes tout foutu tout de la
résolution 242 et 338 du conseil de
sécurité
donc lorsqu'on verra vraiment qu israël
et puis ce voeu est prêt à l'os à ce que
l'on revienne à la paix tout pour chacun
dans cette zone du monde où que israël
se retire de l'ensemble des territoires
occupés en 1967
on reconnaisse les droits légitimes du
peuple palestinien sur le sol
palestinien du tribunal d'autoriser
l'autodétermination et lorsque à 10 h
seront prêts à accepter le retour de la
souveraineté ra sur dans la partie arabe
occupée de la ville de jérusalem
ce qui est important pour des millions
de musulmans et de christian ceux de
chrétiens pardon de parlement
en bout de piste de façon à ce que
jérusalem devienne le symbole de la paix
est l'essence même de la baisse et
lorsque l'ensemble du problème
palestinien sera réglé dans le sens des
résolutions des nations unies et one we
know sur cette question donc encore une
fois lorsque nous saurons que nous
sommes un peu saisir des détails de mise
en oeuvre de ces principes a dit et
lorsque tous à la cure sera prêt pour
partir
danse pour aller dans ce sens donc notre
position est parfaitement clair
notamment depuis le sommet back2back da
ce n'est pas seulement la position de la
jordanie il n'y a pas de refus dans le
monde arabe
notre désir à tous c'est une paix juste
et durable à condition que les
conditions réelles existent comme je les
tiens vous ne regrettez pas complètement
l'initiative de monsieur sadate en
réalité du jeu devant ce qui concerne
l'initiative du président sadate allure
rock witchu nous avons conçu le fait
tourner et un choisi de n'en retenir que
les aspects positifs
nous espérons que cela montrera que les
arabes souhaitent une paix juste et
durable et que tel est leur objective
mais c'était au départ notre position
mais depuis lors et compte tenu du fait
que les gîtes positionnera joue occupe
une position très important dans le
monde arabe et a été lié au restant du
monde arabe fait partie de la ligue
arabe
allez c'est parti d'accords de défense
ex a une responsabilité morale sise à
vis des palestiniens et du problème
palestinien de la bande de gaza 2
la rive occidentale et du gol ans après
tout c'est en 1967 c'est le cours honoré
ses obligations que nous avons combattu
sans beaucoup d'espoir d'obtenir la
victoire
nous pensons donc l'egypte a toujours eu
une obligation morale vis-à-vis du reste
et du monde arabe et le devoir de
rechercher un règlement et dernière
question est-ce qu'il vous semble que
votre position soit proche de la
position française
un double vote je crois effectivement
que la position de la france est une
position qui procède d'une dassoucy des
problèmes de notre région d'une
connaissance des fêtes et d'une prise en
compte des principes fondamentaux et mon
sentiment est que la position de la
france tient compte de la réalité des
problèmes de cette région et je crois
que nous ne sommes pas très loin et très
éloignés l'un de l'autre
merci majesté d'avoir été notre invité
pendant ce journal pendant que nous
parlions j'apprenais que monsieur ventes
ça allait revenir à washington le
vendredi c'est un retour plus tôt que
prévu qui a causé une certaine surprise
on n'en connaît pas la raison pour
l'instant
j'apprenais également que l'italie avait
décidé au parlement son adhésion donc au
s émeut par 270 voix contre 228 donc
malgré le nom des communistes l'italie
rentre bien dans le smb et accepte donc
le principe de l'écu en grande-bretagne
bien les ladies ont frémi aujourd'hui
derrière leurs voiles est et les
gentlemen sont devenus ponceau de honte
en apprenant le renvoi de l'appel de la
sphère james thorpe devant une
juridiction criminelle il devra répondre
de complicité de tentative de meurtre et
d'incitation au meurtre
alors au delà de la personnalité de
l'ancien chef du parti libéral c'est un
coup très dur qui est portée à la fois
son parti et au monde politique
britannique
claude kouassi jeremy ford gentleman
distinguer et plein d'humour avec sur la
tête son éternel chapeau qu'il porte
toujours trop en arrière
membre du conseil privé de la reine
élèves 10 tonnes diplômé d'oxford avocat
succès et ancien leader du parti libéral
il a démissionné pour éviter que son
procès ne ternisse l'image du parti mais
il est trop tard
le parti sort atteint car jeremy sort
après quinze jours d'instruction est
maintenant un accusé et sera jugé pour
complot et incitation au meurtre
l'histoire la voici jeremy flores
pourrait rencontrer en 1961 jeune homme
il a vieilli depuis avec qui il aurait
eu pendant deux ans des relations
amoureuses et les lettres adressées par
lui à norman scott ne laisse pas de
doute sur la passion de leurs sentiments
ce qui se produit ensuite et que norman
scott n'aura de cesse après la rupture
de faire savoir au monde entier qu'il a
été l'amant de jeremy sort alors le
député libéral qui a une carrière
fulgurante devient chef de parti et se
voit proposer un portefeuille de
ministre
p un tueur pour abbas norman scott qui
parlait trop et l'attentât échoue au
cours de l'instruction ou même des
détails d'un tome i habituellement
cachés sont révélés au public abasourdi
jeremy sort pas tous liés mais n'a pas
convaincu il sera jugé le procès risque
d'avoir de sérieuses répercussions
pourquoi harold wilson lorsqu'il était
premier ministre at il essayé d'étouffer
la faire et avec lui d'autres ministres
et chefs de partis qui ne pouvait pas ne
pas être au courant
la réaction la plus commune aujourd'hui
des anglais dans la rue et le dégoût la
classe politique britannique a déjà
perdu aux yeux du public
beaucoup de sa crédibilité
les français le nucléaire un sondage
sofres dans le figaro de demain les
français sont très partagés 47 % sont
favorables à l'énergie nucléaire
42% défavorable pour l'avenir en
revanche 60 % d'entre eux estiment qu'il
faudra accélérer le programme
d'implantation des centrales un rapport
très sévère de l'inspection générale de
l'administration à propos du
fonctionnement de la police rapport
remis le 15 octobre à christian bonnet
révélé cet après midi par le monde près
de 10000 gardiens sont détournés des
tâches de sécurité
certains d'entre eux sont même
secrétaire standardiste chauffeur
jardiniers cuisiniers ou une concierge
10000 gardien ça veut dire 15% des
effectifs de ce corps le ministre de
l'intérieur avait annoncé récemment son
intention de renverser la tendance
violent des mccann ne sera pas extradé
en allemagne de l'ouest la cour d'appel
d'aix en provence a décidé sa mise en
liberté immédiate
james mccann est impliqué dans deux
attentats à l'explosif en allemagne et
puis il y a deux heures j'apprenais que
la célèbre toile de jérôme bosch
l'escamoteur venait d'être dérobés par
deux hommes armés au musée de saint
germain en laye tout près de paris et à
quel prix perreault nous notre pétrole
l'année prochaine eh bien nous sont sans
doute à l'issue de la semaine de
concertation qui a commencé hier à abou
dhabi entre les dix membres de l'opep
on parle pour l'instant d'une hausse de
10% à ce prix bien sûr il est évident
qu'il vaut mieux produire son propre
pétrole
et c'est sans doute une des raisons qui
ont poussé les compagnies pétrolières
françaises à rechercher activement le
précieux liquide en mer d'iroise dans le
golfe de gascogne et même dans la région
parisienne et à ce propos on croit
savoir que l'endroit le plus favorable
serait situé à l'aplomb la tourelle et
puis quatrième zone de prospection le
delta du rhône tout près la camargue
trouver des sources d'énergie bien à
nous c'est le but de notre gouvernement
et par voie de conséquence des
compagnies pétrolières françaises
les recherches puisqu'il ne s'agit
encore que de recherche dans le delta du
rhône ont été décidées parce que cet
endroit offre plusieurs possibilités de
découvrir du pétrole
les études préalables ont montré un
sous-sol géologiquement favorable mais
il faut aller voir un trois ou quatre
mille mètres sous terre si le pétrole
est effectivement là la plateforme de
forage a été amenée de hollande il
ya un mois environ et les travaux ont
commencé le 1er décembre après huit
jours le trou est déjà profond de 500
mais il faut reconnaître que les
conditions sont particulièrement
favorables une plateforme ultramoderne
une profondeur d'eau de 22 m seulement
et une mer plutôt calme on peut aussi
ajouter que les techniciens français
sont parmi les meilleurs du monde et que
des précautions énormes ont été prises
mais le forage se trouve à cinq
kilomètres seulement de la côte et en
camargue on a un peu l'impression
d'avoir été mis devant le fait accompli
alors le permis d'explorer dans cette
zone a été demandée en 1971
nous l'avons obtenue en 1978 nous avons
donc un forage rentrée depuis sept ans
et ça explique très largement la hâte
que nous avons misé ayant le permis pour
forer tout de suite et vous pensez que
c'est important de découvrir
écoutez je pense qu'il est toujours
important de mettre à la disposition de
la france ne serait ce qu'un million de
tonnes de pétrole car ça représente 500
millions de de vivre économiser tout le
problème de ce forage qu'il se trouve
très près d'une côte dans une mer
quasiment fermée est pour le moins déjà
très sale à proximité la réserve
naturelle de camargue où l'équilibré
très précaire où le moindre incident
pourrait provoquer une catastrophe tant
qu'il ne s'agit que de recherche on
n'est pas trop hostile dans la région
par contre si on en trouve on redoute un
afflux d'ouvriers une bousculade de
pétroliers et bien sûr des accidents
comme en bretagne sommes près de la côte
c'est vrai et l'administration en a tenu
compte qui nous a imposé des mesures
tout à fait spécifique ass forage
nous sommes obligés de disposer de 600
mètres de barrages
hors plan polmar que nous aurons
à mettre en doute première urgence entre
la côte et nous sur des coffres qui
viennent d'être posée deuxièmement je
dois dire que le risque est tout de même
très diminué par rapport à un forage
normal pour le fait que nous sommes sur
une auto élévatrice
c'est à dire que tous les organes de
sécurité sont remontés au niveau de la
table et que des pannes de ces organes
sont encore moins vraisemblable que sur
des barges normal ça peut encore arriver
le choix n'est pas facile entre un
besoin stratégique d'énergie que l'on
trouverait chez nous et la protection de
la nature
le choix sera peut-être simple on ne
trouve du pétrole qu'une fois sur dix et
on sait déjà que la camargue en
possédera jamais beaucoup et des forages
sont aussi prévues dans le nord de la
france afin d'examiner s'il n'aurait pas
dû gas ou les mines de charbon
aujourd'hui devant la cour d'assises de
douai
un homme de 33 ans qui a tué deux fois
il ya quatre ans sa femme et un enfant
il a passé plus de la moitié de son
existence en hôpital psychiatrique
une vie donc presque tout entière entre
ces deux types de barrow psychiatrie et
justice une nouvelle fois experts juges
et jurés vont devoir trancher fou ou
coupable mais là étonnant l'accusé
préfère la culpabilité avec tous les
risques que cela comporte
faut le faire les affaires d'aci sont
rarement des récits d'enfants de choeur
mais le dossier ouvert devant les jurés
du doubs et recèle une horreur difficile
à décrire par le même homme
une jeune femme sa femme étranglée avec
une ceinture et un mois plus tard le 13
septembre 74
un enfant de 12 ans tué à coups de
marteau sur la tête après avoir été
brutalisé au sens le plus odieux du mot
le meurtrier serge fera-t-on 33 ans
trapu le front bombé une barbe roussâtre
avec de longs cheveux une voix basse et
brutale alourdi par l'accent du nord
cet homme est sans doute un meurtrier
mais c'est aussi une énigme posée à la
justice un père buveurs hémiplégique une
mère débordée par la marmaille arras et
de travail à 10 ans serge fera-t-on est
placé au centre médico pédagogique
d'armentières c'est le départ d'une
succession de séjour forcé dans une
série d'établissements psychiatriques
seize années de séjour au total sur 33
ans de vie on l'appellait fera-t-on le
fou après l'avoir appelée à l'école
ferrat temps-là fera-t-on la cloche à
cause de ses vêtements dépareillés
servent à faire at-on et de tels hantise
de ce mot de fou qui le poursuit depuis
plus de vingt ans qu'il revendique
l'entière responsabilité de ses actes en
sachant parfaitement qu'il risque ainsi
devant la cour de doué la peine de mort
finalement ce procès est celui d'un
psychopathe dont personne n'a jamais
voulu ni l'hôpital psychiatrique car on
n'a jamais su trop bien comment le
soigner ni la société qui le trouvait
dangereux la preuve alors que reste-t-il
aux jurés
comme promis tradition respectée de
d'après-midi à l'elysée avec comme
chaque année l'arbre de noël serpentins
confettis pour les 500 enfants réunis
pour goûter assister à un spectacle dont
le clou fut à numéro 6 inédit
qu'exclusif
et sa part les chatons moyens différents
et peuvent pas vous dites je peux pas
venir pondre vous à les entendre ils
vont vous dire bonheur 1 2 1
vous comptez voir pour expliquer son
numéro le chef de l'état présentait
lui-même ses deux chiens jus curtat et
samba comme les chiens les moins savants
de france
les enfants qui assistaient à cet arbre
de noël ont été choisis parmi les
écoliers les plus méritants et les plus
déshérités pendant deux heures ils ont
donc chanté avec enrico macias avec
chantal goya et ils ont assisté à des
numéro de ventriloque et de
prestidigitateur après un bon goûter le
chef de l'état et son épouse leur ont
remis des jeux de société sur l'écologie
des panoplies de pompiers de motards des
blocs de cuisine des ballons de football
et des appareils photo le programme que
je suis en train de lire le programme
remis par le président aux enfants et
est illustré par notre dessinateur
maison folie une page sports maintenant
avec ans qui le premier slalom spécial
masculin de la saison à madonna di
campiglio surprise un doublé suisse avec
deux inconnues jusqu'à lors
on attendait stenmark et c'est martial
donnet un suisse de 22 ans à peu près
inconnu qui est arrivé le suédois y ont
complètement raté la première manche
j'ai contracté glissant souplesse sur
une piste aurait des glaces et martial
donnet a été le premier surpris par sa
victoire pour ce premier spéciale de la
saison d'autant plus surpris qu'il est
le premier cette année à faire trébucher
stenmark
et c'est un autre suisse péter en
lüscher qui a pris la deuxième place
devant l'allemand nos oreilles terre
contre le français marc garcia d'abord
classé 9e il était disqualifiée pour
avoir manqué une porte
il y aura un tiercé demain à vincennes
ou aussi les pronostics de pierrette
brès elle a choisi le 14 le vin le 6 le
las donc le numéro un et le neuf ainsi
que 16 pour faire bonne mesure
d'autres chiffres avant la page de la
météo ce du loto comme schumi comme
chaque mercredi
voici la combinaison gagnante le 7 le 15
le 25 le 31 le 42 et le 48 numéro
complémentaire le 12
économisez votre eau cet appel c'est le
préfet de la bourgogne qui l'a lancé
hier soit en raison de la sécheresse qui
sévit qui sévit dans la côte d'or et
puis dans l'ouest cette fois beaucoup de
vent avec cette image vous voyez de la
tempête qui a soufflé toute la nuit
dernière sur tout l'ouest manche et
atlantique des rafales qui ont dépassé
les 90 km heure beaucoup de navires ont
connu des difficultés au large de brest
la mer était très grosse avec des creux
de 10 à 13 mètres et dans l'île de batz
ou l'arthrose poche les pointes de vent
à plus de 120 km demain et bien demain
temps instable avec ondées éparses neige
au dessus de 12 100 m quelques
éclaircies
vent d'ouest toujours assez fort sur les
régions côtières et puis aussi de
l'intérieur
vers 23h15 vous retrouverez pierre-alain
pour les toutes dernières informations
quant à moi je vous retrouverai demain
avec un très grand plaisir bonne soirée
à tous